she's beautiful funny and
she means business
sofia vergara's first commercial was a
big one
pepsi the gig established a key revenue
stream for vergara
who has done several other commercials
for pepsi since
vergara moved to the u.s from colombia
in the 90s to host the travel show
fuere de serie
at the beginning of her career in the
u.s her on-screen jobs weren't frequent
and the pay wasn't great
she was also raising her young son and
needed to build her career to support
them both
one of her first major money-making
ideas happened when she got lunch with
veteran talent manager luis balaguer
the two officially became business
partners in 1994
creating latin world entertainment a
miami-based talent management firm
in 1997 they decided to build out her
fan base in the form of a sofia vergara
bikini calendar
and later contacted distributors to
finance it and it worked
the calendar retailed for 12.95 and
ended up selling close to a million
copies
it was then that vargara learned that
there was real money in being the face
of products
latin world entertainment has since
grown into a media powerhouse that
handles licensing
marketing production and development as
her firm grew
so did her on-screen career landing
roles in chasing poppy
four brothers and tyler perry's meet the
browns
and since her pepsi days she's
advertised for synthroid
mcdonald's valley total fitness cover
cerveza aguila charisma dolce gabbana
procter gamble and pepsi again one day
pepsi please and one of her highest
paying and longest lasting endorsements
was head and shoulders
you know the brand that very few
celebrities wanted to endorse
but there's even more money in licensing
after she signed her first licensing
contract with kmart in 2011
vergara made seven figures off her
clothing line with the retailer each
year until she ended the deal in 2015.
she went on to forge licensing deals
with brands like shark ninja and
furniture chain rooms to go
in 2020 vergara's role as gloria on
modern family came to an end after 11
seasons
and during that final season she made
about nine million dollars
her current role as a judge on america's
got talent pays eight figures
and whatever her on-screen future holds
her business acumen proves it will be a
huge success